his ex objects to requests in his texts
yes that means it's time for
an entire segment about Jonah Hill who
I said Jonah Hill
yeah I bet you never thought you'd heard
that on this show but now you did actor
Jonah Hill is at the center of a huge
controversy over his ex Sarah Brady who
released their private text messages
claiming it's proof of his emotional
abuse usually he's only accused of
abusing the eyeballs of movie viewers
but let's check out some of his tasks
texts and debate if he's a jerk or not
quote plain and simple if you need
surfing with men to post pictures of
yourself in a bathing suit friendships
with women who are unstable places I am
not the right partner for you if these
things bring you up to a place of
happiness I support it and there will be
no hard feelings these are my boundaries
for romantic partnership
Kudlow sent me the same thing
doesn't seem that unreasonable to me
though they also went back and forth
over her social media picks she writes
quote any more specific ones that bother
you he replied yes one that isn't of
your ass in a thong
she responds not a thong but k
EP I believe K is short for okay
thank you considering she's a
professional Surfer and those are her
work clothes however that is quite an
ask what else is she gonna wear the
couple has been broken up for over a
year but Sarah says she's coming forward
now because she wants to be famous
I mean to heal from her trauma
Jonah hasn't released a statement yet
but if he wants the whole world to read
it he can probably just privately text
it to his ex just don't turn it into a
movie because then No One's Gonna See
that am I right
now that we laid out the facts it's time
to decide
is Jonah Hill hey
hero or jerk
he's okay he's obviously a jerk okay and
I think we get way down in this debate
of whether or not he qualifies for this
or that therapy speak no offense Drew
your face therapy dude but obviously
he's a jerk okay he's like listen no no
bathing suit photos no modeling she's a
surfer slash model if those are his
boundaries date one of the literally
billions of women who are not Surfer
slash models instead of being like I
want a girlfriend who doesn't model and
who doesn't surf hi Surfer lady would
you like to go on a date with me and
then afterwards I'm gonna tell you
shouldn't surf or model um I didn't know
there were a lot of surfers who slash
models I'm not for that there are even
fewer yeah now they are all right so Dr
Drew uh is this you this is your area of
expertise have you ever had Jonah Hill
as a patient no do you know of John Hill
I do but are you guys close have you
been lovers no neither uh and if I were
a patient I couldn't tell you but leave
the guy alone okay for God is she
picking on him cat the cat is I rarely
disagree with my friend Cass I just said
he's a jerk and uh and I agree with the
frame that he shouldn't have been dating
her it's like somebody that goes I've
somebody goes to you've had friends that
do this they date a strip or I can
handle it no problem then I'll have a
baby by one and have to raise the baby
yeah I know and then they say stop
tripping
I was talking about me but the point is
guys
sorry sorry doc I'm with you
but you know what I'm saying that I
can't think it was Dacia to be fair
that guys do this all the time and Cap's
right that's not okay it's wrong to do
that but he did it in a no no I'm saying
to to say to go out with somebody that
is a bathing suit model and is a surfer
and they'd get mad at her for having
pictures in a bathing suit is
unreasonable but the way he asked to
change is perfectly healthy he said I
can't take this we gotta go this reminds
me of that time in the seven it was like
the 1980s I was dating Mother Teresa and
I just told her to stop helping people I
was saying yeah you're constantly
helping people and it's taking away from
our time and I said it's either me or
the orphan since you chose me
and then you left her I dumped her she
went I dumped her first be with someone
who wouldn't help out orphans yeah I
dumped a first stripper but you know the
thing is we all have different needs and
you got to follow your heart am I right
Jamie do you ever follow your heart or
what's left of it after it was crushed
by your ex-wife it's hard to follow the
heart because the pieces are so small
but um yeah I I wish there was more
choices because it's like hero or jerk
you know I feel like it lies somewhere
in between like he's um I think he's I
don't know I think something happened in
the past that led to this or else I feel
I had a girl
I had a girl tell me to stop doing
comedy once and it wasn't a girlfriend
it was just this girl that saw my show
this week
stole your thunder got Phil you sure
wasn't Greg Gutfeld yeah but I like that
he was setting boundaries like I would
set boundaries but like no one no one's
trying to get in you know
um you know how with relationships in
life I yeah I sometimes try to provide
advice right yeah oh you have some for
us I do I have one oh here we go
oh
so's lessons tips from a divorced dad
foreign
you know having a kid can cost upwards
of two hundred thousand dollars
but they say if you don't have kids
you'll die alone
I don't know though with that two
hundred thousand dollars you could buy
like a pool table and you probably get
like a bunch of tigers
so you wouldn't die alone you'd be
surrounded by tigers
[Music]
last word
uh I'm kind of surprised in this one
because the one thing that I know cat is
a stickler from is she does not condone
putting your butt on Instagram she is in
the no butt free zone actually had a
hilarious post not too long where you
put a giant black box up so people could
slide and see an even smaller black box
over it and then you slide and it was
actually thinking that that will be my
butt but it was actually a larger black
yeah well played he's not a hero he's
not a jerk he's a regular guy with some
insecurities who put boundaries out
there and he didn't have a problem with
her surfing because most Surfers who
surf wear wetsuits his problem was
taking pictures with your thong with a
bunch of dudes and he said I can't ride
this train with you that way if that's
what you're gonna do I'm gonna move see
he was being factual and keeping it real
and direct yeah and we don't know how
long in the thread see never ever ever
trust a text in a piece yeah about you
because chances are he had a three-yard
strand of her talking to him yeah and
then he finally said you know what these
are my boundaries and I'm not gonna I
don't like this anymore and that's the
part she showed let's see the whole
strand let's see the where were you last
night yeah all right
on that note that's a great point that
is a great point we are living in a time
of society where we don't care about
context anymore like right now you could
just say I could say I hate Jamie's guts
well actually it doesn't need any
contacts no
you've told me that before allegedly yes
coming up the fur babies who give you
rabies Greg's animal friends is next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else